in this video I'm going to be helping
you prepare for the algebra two final
exam if you want to jump to a particular
type of question or problem go to the
description below I've got time stamps
will take you right to that type of
problem also if you need to review
algebra 2 first semester concepts check
out the video that I did regarding the
algebra 2 midterm exam let's jump right
into this video talking about question
number one it says x and y vary
inversely y equals three when x equals
negative 8 write an equation that
relates x and y and then it says find y
when x equals 4 okay so what they're
testing us on here first of all is just
knowing the basic equation when two
variables vary inversely and that's
going to look something like this y
equals a divided by x now remember a is
a constant of variation some books use
the letter K it doesn't really matter
it's just a constant it's a number that
ties these two variables together but
the key thing here is is that X is in
the denominator so let's go ahead and
write an equation what we're gonna do
we're going to put 3 in place of Y and
negative 8 in place of X so we've got 3
equals a divided by negative 8 now if I
multiply both sides by negative 8 right
that's going to give us a equals
negative 24 now all I have to do is put
that negative 24 back and for a right
and we've got y equals negative 24
divided by X and that's our equation
that relates to two variables now Part B
says find y when X is 4 all we have to
do is put 4 in place of X and we've got
it so that's y equals 24 divided by 4 so
we know that Y is equal to negative 6 so
very important inverse variation
equations now question number 2 says
that Z okay varies jointly with X&Y ok
so now we're switching to joint
variation and it says that they give us
some information Z equals negative 72
when X is 9 and Y is negative 4 so they
give us that information to help us to
solve for the constant of variation
okay so Part A says writing equation
relates the variables and Part B says
find Z when X is 6 and Y is 4 ok so
first things first see how it says Z
varies jointly so this is like Z varies
jointly with x and y if it said Y varies
jointly with X and Z then I would have Y
over here on the left
side of the equation but you can just
follow that order Z varies jointly so
you can see these two variables are
multiplied together and you've got that
a value that constant of variation like
we had in this previous question okay so
now what we want to do is we want to
plug in all the quantities that we have
here so negative 72 X we know is 9 right
and Y is negative 4 so if we simplify it
we get negative 36 a negative 36 a
equals negative 72 divided by negative
36 and you can see that a is coming out
to positive 2 so all we have to do now
is put 2 back in for a and that's our
equation so let me write that down here
for us Z equals 2 times X times y so
then Part B all we have to do now is put
6 in place of X and 4 in place of Y and
then we can solve for Z so one thing to
be careful of is when you look at the Z
sometimes it looks like a 2 that's why I
put that little line through the middle
there just so we don't get confused so
that's Z equals 2 times X which is 6
times y which is 4 so let's see that's
going to be 24 times 2 which is 48 okay
so basically it's like a three-step
process when you do these problems
you've got your general equation okay so
Z equals 8 times X times y you plug in
your values to find out the constant of
variation or your a value and you put
that back in that gives you a more
specific equation now we've got that
more specific equation we can use the
other values that they're giving us to
solve for Z so it's kind of like three
parts okay question number three says
write an equation again where D varies
directly with M and inversely with the
cube of P okay so this is what they call
combined variation and basically what
you're doing here is you're saying D
varies directly with M okay but
inversely with the cube of P so notice
whatever was varying inversely I put in
the denominator
whatever was varying directly I put in
the numerator and you always want to
remember to put your constant of
variation either a or K whatever you
know constant of variation variable your
teacher prefers and that's our equation
so that's combined variation Part B says
that R varies jointly with y so R varies
jointly with Y and the square root of x
so square root of x now remember just
like this question we do it over here
Z equals a times X times y see how the
variables are all multiplied together
that's joint variation same thing here
you can see that Y and the square root
of x are multiplied together and we've
got our constant of variation of a so
these ones are basically like a combined
variation they call it okay now for
number four what we have here is a y
equals negative two divided by X minus
one plus three we want to graph it find
the domain the range and the equations
of the asymptotes now there's a couple
of different ways to do this problem but
the way that I like to do it is I like
to think about your your parent function
which is y equals e divided by ax okay
so in this case our parent function is
this guy right here it's y equals
negative two divided by X that's going
to give us the shape of the graph then
what happens is the number that's
grouped with the ax
that's going to pick up the graph and
shift it in the X direction left and
right okay and the one that's not group
of the axis one over here is going to
shift it up and down that's gonna be
your vertical shift so if I was to write
this in a more general way let me put it
over here we've got y equals a divided
by X minus h plus K H comma K is the
shift now the thing you want to remember
is that the number this group with the X
has the opposite effect on the graph so
X minus one is actually going to shift
this graph right one and that's going to
give us the vertical asymptote right
there okay so that's going to be the
line x equals one and the reason is is
because if you put one in here one minus
one is zero we can't divide by zero
that's undefined right
okay now the plus three what that does
is it shifts the graph up three so one
two three we have a horizontal asymptote
right here at y equals three okay so you
can see we found our asymptotes let's
write those down
x equals one y equals three okay now the
next thing we want to do is we want to
think about this point right here as
like our new origin instead of graphing
from here we're going to think about
starting from here and then what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to use the
parent function y equals negative two
over X to make a table of values okay
and what are good values to pick well I
would pick a couple of negative values
and a couple of positive values this way
we can plot some points on this side of
the vertical asymptote and then on the
right side of the vertical asymptote so
let's see if we put negative two in
negative two divided by negative two is
1 negative two divided by negative
one is positive 2 negative 2 divided by
1 is negative 2 and negative 2 divided
by 2 is negative 1 so all we have to do
now is plot these points from our
shifted origin and let me go ahead and
do that here so we're going to go left 2
up 1 so that's right here we're gonna go
left 1 up 2 so that's right here so you
can see this branch of the graph is
actually looking something like this ok
so it's getting closer and closer to the
asymptotes okay but doesn't touch
doesn't cross and then over here we've
got right 1 down 2 so right about there
and then right 2 down 1 so from here 1 2
down 1 so you can see something very
similar on this side ok again it's
approaching those asymptotes doesn't
touch doesn't cross so when we think
about the domain the domain is whatever
the x-values can be so like left and
right right we already talked about how
X can't be 1 because you're you'd be
dividing by 0 and that's undefined so
what you can do for the domain I'm going
to use the interval notation I'm gonna
say we're gonna go from negative
infinity up to 1 not including 1 that's
why we're using the parenthesis not the
bracket Union 1 to positive infinity
right so we're basically skipping over 1
because that's where the vertical
asymptote is now for the range those are
the y-values we think about what can y
be so that's up and down right so it can
go from negative infinity all the way up
to 3 not including 3 and then above that
point so it's going to be from negative
infinity to 3 Union 3 to positive
infinity so that's our domain and range
and basically again what they're testing
us on is this equation here y equals a
over X minus h plus K and again if you
look at that parent function right here
see y equals a divided by X that's our
inverse variation equation and that's
our parent function that's what we work
with here so if you need to review this
problem go ahead and do so I also have
videos on all these different topics on
my Mara's math tutor YouTube channel so
if you get stuck or you want to see more
practice problems you know go ahead and
go over to my YouTube page you know type
in inverse variation and you will be
able to track down more videos about
these same topics but let's go on to the
next question okay question number 5
they're asking us to simplify and
basically what they're testing us out on
these three parts are you know our
factoring skills so you definitely want
to review factor
if you've forgotten some of the
techniques but the first thing when I
recognize here is that we're doing a
difference of two squares x squared is a
perfect square 16 is a perfect square
and you're subtracting the two so when
you factor this what you have is ax
times X's gives you the x squared right
four times four gives you the 16 one of
these is adding one of these is
subtracting okay so that's the key when
you factor a difference of two squares
for the denominator we've got a leading
coefficient of one it's a trinomial and
we just have to ask ourselves what two
numbers multiply to 12 but add to
negative seven so in this case again we
know x times X gives us the x squared
negative four times negative three
multiplied to positive twelve but when
we do the inner product and the outer
product see negative 4x and negative 3x
that adds up to the middle term negative
7x so now that we have it factored what
we can do is we can cancel the factors
in the numerator denominator the same so
both of those are X minus 4 they cancel
out and we're left with X plus 4 over X
minus 3 now one thing that I did mention
in this problem but sometimes you might
encounter this when you're taking your
final exam is somebody they'll ask you
for the excluded values and excluded
values means what X cannot be in this
case if you look at just the final
answer you might say to yourself well X
can't be 3 because 3 minus 3 is 0 and I
know I can't divide by 0 right but what
you want to do really is you want to
factor this as much as you can look at
the denominator before you reduce or
cancel and then analyze the excluded
values so here you can see really X
cannot be positive 4 because 4 minus 4
is 0 and X can't equal positive 3
because that would make this 0 so before
you cancel that's when you look at your
excluded values but this would be your
final answer okay for letter B now what
we have is 5x plus 20 over 3x squared
plus 11x minus 4 the first step in
factoring of course is always to look
for the greatest common factor in this
case I can see I can divide out a 5 out
of 5 x + 20 and so that's like 5 times X
+ 4 it's like doing the distributive
property backwards the denominator a
little bit more challenging because we
have a trinomial but the leading
coefficient is 3 so a lot of students
will use what they call the trial and
error method or guess and check method
you can also do a technique called
splitting the middle term and factor by
grouping or what
they sometimes called the AC method but
in this case I'm just going to jump in
and just do the trial and error method
and I recognize that this is going to be
3 X minus 1 times X plus 4 because
negative 1 X and positive 12 X add up to
the 11x the middle term but negative 1
times 4 give me the last term negative 4
again where you can review a video that
I did it's called learn how to factor on
my mario's math tutor YouTube channel
and it goes through all the different
types of factoring but now look what
happens we've got an X plus 4 in the
numerator and X plus 4 in the
denominator those cancel and so we're
left with 5/3 X minus 1 another quick
notice as we're going through this you
know extensive review you might want to
try to beat me to it and see if you can
do these problems before I complete them
you know maybe pause the video and then
you can check to see if you're on the
right track
if you want to follow along that's fine
too so here what we have is actually a
division problem and remember when you
divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal so some
students will say keep it change it flip
it and so what that means you keep the
first fraction you change this division
sign to multiplication but you have to
flip the won't fraction you're dividing
by the second fraction so what I'm going
to do here is I'm going to factor this
so x squared minus 9 is actually X plus
3 times X minus 3 that's a difference of
two squares
2x minus 8 we can factor out a 2 so
that's going to be X minus 4 times 2
divide I'm going to change this to
multiplication but then I'm going to
take the reciprocal so if I flip this
over I'm going to factor the denominator
which comes out to X minus 4 X plus 3
see I move that up here and then 4x
minus 12 I can factor out a 4 and that's
going to give you X minus 3 times 4 okay
so now that we have it all factored this
is kind of the fun part you can reduce
numerator and denominator or on the
diagonals a numerator and denominator so
as long as the ones on the top ones on
the bottom you can cancel so see these X
minus 3s I'm gonna cancel those guys out
ok you see the X minus 4s I'm going to
cancel those out top and bottom and then
that's all we can do so what I'm gonna
do here is I'm just going to multiply
across and this is X plus 3 times
another X plus 3 so I'm gonna write it a
little bit more condensed as X plus 3
squared 2 times 4 is 8 and so that's
going to be our final result okay now
let's go to number 6 so number 6 says
subtract so just like when we learned
subtracting fractions you
back in pre-algebra now what we're doing
is we're subtracting but you can see the
denominators are not just integers or
fractions they're basically polynomials
right in this case you've got two
binomials but we still want to get that
common denominator that's the same as
what we learned before so in this case
what's the common denominator of X minus
5 and X plus 4 well if you said that
it's actually X minus 5 times X plus 4
you're right but the key here is you see
how this first fraction it has an X
minus 5 but not an X plus 4 that means
we have to multiply the top and bottom
by what it's missing right so I'm going
to multiply the numerator by X plus 4
and the denominator by X plus 4 because
X plus 4 divided by X plus 4 is 1 and
when you multiply by 1 it's not going to
change the overall value of that
fraction right it's just gonna change
the way that it looks this one we have
an X plus 4 but we're missing an X minus
5 so I'm going to multiply the numerator
and denominator by X minus 5 so that's
gonna be 2 times X minus 5 all over X
minus 5 X plus 4 okay see with me so far
we've got common denominators now what
we want to do is we want to combine the
numerators so let me just go ahead and
distribute here this is giving us 3x
Plus 8 right 3x plus 8 and then you see
this minus sign here's where students
make a little bit of a mistake so a
minus is really like a negative so you
could think of this as like a negative 2
and you can distribute the negative 2 so
that's a little bit easier that's going
to give you negative 2 X and negative 2
times a negative 5 is a positive 10 and
let me just combine these together now
so 3x minus 2 X is 1 X 8 plus 10 is 18
right and this is all divided by that
common denominator and your teacher will
generally let you leave this denominator
in factored form and the reason you want
to do that is because sometimes what
happens is you can factor the numerator
further and you'll get some cancellation
that occurs top and bottom but the key
here really is to get the common
denominators combine them into one
fraction okay so let's go to number 7 so
number 7 we're getting into solving
equations okay we got three parts here
the first one notice that we have
essentially what is left proportion a
proportion is a ratio equal to another
ratio a fraction equal to another
fraction and the easiest way to solve
these problems is just to cross multiply
you know cross that diagonal sign so
that product meaning those multiplied
together equals this product those
multiply together so if I do that 3
- - just gives us 3x minus 6 if I do 1
times 2x minus 1 of course 1 times
anything is itself now all we have to do
is solve this equation I'm going to
subtract 2x from both sides and that's
1x I'm going to add 6 to both sides
that's 5 that's our answer but the one
thing you want to be careful about when
you're doing these types of problems is
remember you can never divide by 0 so
you don't want transfer to come out to 2
because 2 minus 2 is 0 you don't want
your answer to come out to 1/2 because 2
times 1/2 is 1 minus 1 is 0 right but it
looks like here our answer came out to 5
so as long as you're not making the
denominator 0 that's a good answer
otherwise it's considered extraneous you
want to throw that answer out okay so
you with me so far
okay now here for Part B what we have is
we've actually got three equations okay
and there's a couple different ways to
solve this problem one way to do it is
to combine these two guys into one
fraction and then what will happens like
a proportion like we had for Part A and
we could cross multiply and solve it
that way but generally what your teacher
will show you in your class when you're
learning about this is to clear the
denominators and the way you do that is
you but you multiply by a common
denominator for all three of these
fractions so what's the common
denominator of 6 3 and 18 well if you
said 18 you're right so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna multiply this whole
thing by 18 which is like 18 over 1
right so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
distribute distribute distribute as long
as you're doing the same thing you know
both sides of the equation you multiply
every term by 18 it keeps the equation
balanced it doesn't change the equation
okay so basically what we're to do is
we're gonna do 18 and then divided by 6
that comes out to 3 here we got negative
18 X divided by 3 is negative 6 X right
and then over here you can see the 18s
are cancelling and we're just left with
5 so that's the idea is it clears the
denominator when you multiply through
that by that common denominator making
it easier to solve because you don't
have any fractions right so now I'm
going to subtract 3 from both sides so
that gives me 2 right divide everything
by negative 6 left and right side so
that's going to give us negative 2 6
which is negative 1/3 now again remember
the key is when you're working with
these types of irrational equations you
don't want your denominator to equal 0
in this case where there's no danger of
that because we have constants in the
denominator but it's good just to
quickly check to make sure you're not
dividing by 0 you don't have to solve
the whole equation again unless you have
time you want to see if you got
right answer you're mainly just looking
for those extraneous solutions okay the
Part C now this was a little bit more
challenging and any integer you can
think of as a fraction by putting it
over one so I'm gonna do that really
quick the other thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to factor this denominator
which comes out to what X minus 3 and X
plus 2 ok so now what we can do is we
can analyze what's the common
denominator what's the lowest common
denominator well you can see this has an
X plus 2 this has a 1 this has an X
minus 3 and an X plus 2 so to get that
same denominator that common denominator
see this guy is really missing an X
minus 3 so what we're gonna do here okay
I'm going to do a slightly different
technique just to show you the different
types of things you might encounter
depending on how your teacher is or what
method your teacher prefers I'm gonna
try to get everything to have the same
denominator okay so I'm just going to
multiply this by X minus 3 over X minus
3 so you can see now we've got the same
denominators right but what about this
guy well this guy is actually missing an
X minus 3 right and an X plus 2 so we
have to multiply the numerator times X
minus 3 times X plus 2 but remember
that's this whole quantity here so I'm
just going to write that as x squared
minus X minus 6 okay so you're with me
so far
so the key I was focusing on us try to
get the all the denominators to be the
same now what you can do is some
teachers will say well we can just cover
up those denominators okay and just
focus on the numerators but really
what's happening it's just like what we
did over here is we multiplied through
by the common denominator if I multiply
through everything by X plus 2 X minus 3
X plus 2 X minus 3 X plus 2 X minus 3
what's canceling out is the denominator
now so we're clearing those denominators
just like we did here I think a lot of
students find a little bit easier just
to get that common denominator first
then just focus on the numerators
because we're multiplying through or
clearing those denominators okay so
let's let's focus on the numerators now
so I'm just going to clear these really
quick so what we've got is let's foil
this out so 3x times X gives us 3 x
squared right
3x times negative 3 gives us negative 9
X negative 2 times X is negative 2x and
negative 2 times negative 3 is positive
6 over here we have plus the 5 I'm going
to distribute to all three of these guys
that's going to give us 5x squared minus
five X minus 30 and then over here you
can see that we're just left with
negative 24 because the denominators
cancelled right with the numerator when
we cleared the denominators so now what
we have is we have this equation but at
least it doesn't have any fractions in
it let's combine like terms so we've got
5 x squared + 3 x squared which is 8x
squared right and what else do we have
we've got 9x and negative 2 X which is a
negative 11x okay - 5 X which is
negative 16 X and we've got 6 and
negative 30 which is how much that's
negative 24 equals negative 24 now if we
add 24 to both sides those are going to
cancel so this is equal to 0 so we've
got 8 x squared minus 16 x equals 0 I'm
going to factor out the greatest common
factor which is 8 X now that we have it
factored we can set each factor equal to
0 so we get x equals 0 or x equals 2 so
I'm just handing the two to the other
side now here's the thing when you take
a look at this you want again you want
to check the denominators you want to
make sure you're not dividing by 0 so
here it looks like X came out to 2 which
is okay because 2 plus 2 is 4 that
doesn't equal 0 if it came out to
negative 2 that would be extraneous I'd
have to cross that out okay now over
here it can X equal 0 yep looks like
we're not dividing by 0 so only if X is
negative 2 or x equals 3 would it be an
extraneous solution so in this case we
actually got two answers sometimes you
get just one of the two works you know
you get one answer works one answer
doesn't work and sometimes both answers
don't work they're both extraneous and
there's just no solution and that's fine
too so you just want to make sure you
quickly double-check so let's go on to
the next question okay question number 8
it says find the distance between the
points 3 negative 8 and negative 4 16
and Part B says find the midpoint
between these two points
so obviously what they're testing us on
in this question is you know make sure
that we remember the distance formula
the midpoint formula two important
formulas so what you want to do for the
distance formula is you want to subtract
the x coordinates in square subtract the
Y coordinates to square add those
together and take the square root so let
me see if I can fit that in right here
so we've got distance equals the square
root of x2 minus x1 squared plus y2
minus y1 squared okay
so if we do that I've got negative 4
minus 3 which is negative 7 negative 7
squared is 49 plus 16 minus negative 8
which is how much that's going to be 24
24 squared is 576 if we add those
together and take the square root we get
625 the square root of 625 is 25 so
again just review your distance formula
if you need to Part B is asking us about
the midpoint now remember the midpoint
formula it's like an average you're
you're adding the x-coordinates together
and you're dividing by two and you're
adding the y-coordinates together and
dividing by two so that's how you find
the middle it's like an average if you
get an 80% on the test 100% you add them
together 180 points divided by two your
average so far is 90 right so what we've
got here is we got negative six plus six
is 0 divided by 2 is 0 8 plus 4 is 12 12
1 by 2 is 6 so 0 comma 6 would be the
midpoint between these two points
ok so review your distance in midpoint
formula number 9 we're starting to get
into some probability and it says in a
hat there are 7 blue marbles 3 red
marbles 5 white marbles right and here
it says what's the probability that you
pick a blue marble so you can see P of B
if probability that you get a blue
marble well remember what probability is
it's the number of successful outcomes
or I'll just say the number of successes
what you want right divided by the total
possible outcomes the total possible
things that could happen well in this
case you have 7 chances of picking a
blue marble out of a total of 15 you
know possible marbles that you could
draw out of this hat right so 7 chances
of getting what you want out of 15
marbles total so probably 7 out of 15 so
just kind of a basic probability
question but understanding that formula
for probability is key so number 10 it
says if you have six different books how
many ways can you order them on a shelf
ok now there's a couple different ways
to do this problem one way is you can
visualize it like this
here's your shelf and you say ok I want
to put you know my first book right here
or how many choices do I have for that
first book to place in that first
position well you have six choices but
once you place that book how many
choices then when you have
to place that second book well since you
put a book here there's only five books
left and you can see it's going down
four three two one and then what you do
is you multiply these together this is
called the fundamental counting
principle or sometimes called a
multiplication counting principle but
you can see this is six five four three
two one or you could write this as six
factorial so the exclamation point means
you start at six you multiply down to
one so it's a way of how many ways are
there to order and items okay
that's n factorial but in this case if
we simplify all this out we get seven
hundred and twenty different orderings
okay so that's the key for that problem
so number eleven says you have a
combination lock with each number from
zero to nine okay so you can dial in
this combination zero to nine for the
first number zero to nine for the second
number zero to nine for the third number
so I'll just kind of diagram it out like
that and it says how many three number
combinations are there if no repetition
is allowed so again I know writing it
out like this sometimes is helpful you
say how many choices are there for the
first number now sometimes students make
a mistake they say oh there's nine but
that's if you count one two three four
five six seven eight nine but plus the
zero that means there's actually ten
choices for what you can dial into this
combination for the first digit right
but if you can't repeat the numbers once
you pick that number seven say for
example there's only going to be nine
choices left for the second digit right
and then once you use those two those
are going to be eight left for the third
so you see how it goes down because
there's no repetition you can't keep
using see if it'll rose a repetition to
be ten choices for this one ten choices
for this one ten for this that would be
ten cubed that'd be a thousand but in
this case it's going to be going down
because you can't repeat so this is 72
times ten there's 720 you know different
or unique combinations now Part B says
the first number can't be a zero okay so
let's kind of diagram this out it can't
be a zero that means it could be a one
through nine so we have nine choices
here right and the last digit must be an
odd number well let's see how many odd
numbers are there from zero to nine well
there's one three five seven and nine so
there's five or so you have five choices
here now notice it says the digits can
be repeated okay so you can use the same
number 3 3 3 or 2 2 2 right but then how
many choices are for this this middle
digit here
well again we can use any number zero
through nine so that's actually ten
possibilities so if we multiply these
together we get nine times ten times
five which is how much well that's 90
times five that's going to be four
hundred and fifty different combinations
that have an odd number for the last
digit doesn't start for zero for the
first digit the middle digit can be
anything from zero to nine so that's the
key that's the fundamental counting
principle or the multiplication counting
principle so if you're enjoying this
video so far and you like my teaching
style and you're preparing for the AC T
or the SAT specifically the math section
check out my two courses I've got one
for the AC T one for the SAT we go
through a teaching section we go through
example problems we go through formulas
we go through different ways to approach
problems so that when you take that test
you're prepared you know to boost your
score so I have had a lot of students
that have taken the courses already
reported back that they've been able to
improve their math section score quite a
bit and I believe that you will too but
I've got three free lessons they're
available for you if you want to click
on the link you can take those three
free lessons you'll definitely benefit
from those and if you want to learn more
and take the course you know I encourage
you to do that but let's keep going on
with this video and we'll help you
prepare for your algebra two final exam
okay if you're liking this video make
sure to give this video a thumbs up so I
know to make more reviews and final exam
reviews like this for you in the future
but let's continue so number 12 it says
you're picking representatives for a
student committee there are two spots to
fill and 20 industries interested
candidates in how many ways can the two
spots be filled and it says that the
jobs are identical okay so this is very
interesting here so you basically what
you have is you've got two spots 20
candidates and the question I want to
ask you is does the order matter or does
the order not matter it doesn't matter
whether is it like there's gonna be a
person that's a president and a vice
president or the two positions the same
well it says that the jobs are identical
so that's the key here in this problem
what they're testing us on are
permutations and combinations so you
probably remember from your math class
okay earlier NPR and NCR
right so what you can think about is
permutations the order matters
combinations the order does not matter
so in this case it's a
combinations it's NCR and so what we
want is out of twenty were choosing two
so twenty combination two and if you use
the formula remember the formula for
combinations is like this it's NCR
equals n factorial over n minus R
factorial our factorial okay like that
so in this case what we have is we've
got 20 factorial over 20 minus 2 which
is 18 factorial times 2 factorial and
then you can simplify that out but
what's interesting about the factorials
is you start at 20 times 19 times 18
times 17 all the way down to 1 and see
18 is 18 times 17 all the way down to 1
so those are going to cancel so you're
just gonna end up with in the numerator
20 times 19 and the denominator gonna
have 2 times 1 which is 2 20 divided by
2 is 10 times 19 is a hundred and ninety
now a lot of calculators you know you
can just plug in on your calculator 20
choose two and get the answer but
sometimes your teacher will have you
show the work like this but now when you
do the formula for permutations NPR it's
almost the exact same formulas what we
have here but instead of dividing by R
factorial you just have n factorial over
n minus R factorial you don't have that
our factorial here because what you're
doing is you're dividing out the
multiplicities because the order doesn't
matter with combinations okay so let's
look at number 13 now it says how many
distinguishable permutations are there
of the word algebra okay this is a
common problem and remember a
permutation is like an ordering that's
like how many ways can we take these
letters reorder them make a different
word so it looks different right
well you can see we've got 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
letters so that means there's 7
factorial ways of ordering 7 items right
just like that book example we did
earlier in this video
but notice how there's two A's so what
we have to do is we have to divide out
those two A's because 2 factorial that's
there's two different ways to order
these aids like if I change these
positions you would still see the word
algebra wouldn't be a different word it
wouldn't be distinguishable right so now
all you have to do is uh simplify this
now I'll go to the calculator right here
I'll show you another example real quick
too as well so 7 math factorial let's
see that's 5000 40 divided by 2 which
comes out to two thousand five hundred
and twenty different permutations not
the the granddaddy of them all is the
Mississippi right mi SS is s IPP I write
there's eleven letters so that's 11
factorial but we've got four asses so
we're gonna divide out the 4 factorial
we've got 4 eyes and we have two peas
and if you simplify that down that's the
number of ways to order the letters in
Mississippi but like again you know you
can see fact 4 factorial is actually 24
there's gonna be twenty four different
ways to rearrange these letters let's
say for example the esses but it would
still look like the word mississippi so
that's what you want to do is divide out
those multiples okay now number 14 it
says in a track race of ten runners and
how many ways can the runners finish
first second and third so let me ask you
a quick question do you think the order
matters yeah definitely right because
you know it's first second third this
person gets gold silver bronze right so
when the order matters you want to think
permutations when the order doesn't
matter you think combinations okay so
this is a permutation and what we're
looking at here is ten P three so what I
like to say is that a ten you're picking
three like P or picking but the order
matters that's why we're using the
permutation so if we use our formula
it's ten factorial over ten minus three
seven factorial now notice I didn't
divided by our factorial that's only if
the order doesn't matter so then if what
you can do here is this is really going
to be ten times nine times eight times
seven all the way down to one right
seven factorial seven six five four
three two all way down to one you can
see those are all going to cancel and
we're just left with ten times nine
times eight which is seven hundred and
twenty different ways for these people
to finish first second third now you
might be saying to yourself well Mario
couldn't I just go like this there's ten
choices for who finish this first once
that person finish this first there's
nine choices for who finishes second and
then once I pick those two there's only
eight people left to finish third yeah
that's exactly right there's 720
different ways you could use that
fundamental kind of fundamental counting
principle or the multiplication counting
principle like we talked about earlier
but sometimes students just like to
think about it in this way you know just
a little bit easier out of 10 I'm
picking 3 the order matters you know
over here we had out of 20 we were
choosing to the order didn't matter okay
so you're with me so far
so now number 15 and 16 were getting
into the binomial expansion theorem so
if you want to review this concept more
you can go to my
mastering YouTube channel lookup
binomial expansion theorem where I've
got more examples but it says find the
coefficient of x to the fourth in the
binomial expansion now it's a final exam
right time is of the essence right so we
don't necessarily want to write this out
seven times and foil it we don't
necessarily want to do Pascal's triangle
and go all the way down to the seventh
role what we want to do is we want to be
able to zero in on X to the fourth term
so what I'm gonna do here is I'm going
to show you we've got two X that's our
first term negative three that's our
second term in our binomial right
binomials too and what we've got is we
have two seventh row and we know that we
want this to be X to the four so that
means this exponent is for these two
exponents always add up to this power so
this is going to be three and then these
guys are always gonna match okay so if
you want a formula you can write it like
this like say if you have like a plus B
to the N right this is gonna be like and
choose K write a and B to the K and this
is going to be a to the N minus K okay
so basically these two exponents are
going to add up to this exponent this is
whatever role you're on or whatever
power this is these match and then this
K value here and this K value are gonna
match now the idea is okay so that once
you get to this point if we simplify it
seven choose three I'll show you more
but seven factorial over 7 minus 3 is 4
factorial times 3 factorial this is
going to be 2 to the 4th which is 16 X
to the fourth negative 3 cubed is
negative 27 and now if we multiply all
this together let's see what we get we
get let's see 7 factorial which you said
was 5040 from the previous problem
divided by let's see 4 factorial it's 24
and then in 3 factorial 6 because they
comes out to 35 okay then times 16 times
negative 27 okay so we're at negative
15,000 120 X to the fourth but we just
want the coefficient so you would just
write the negative 15,000 120 okay but I
don't want to leave you hanging here so
basically what I want to show you is
that remember Pascal's triangle we've
got 1 1 1 2 1 1 3 3 1
and so on and so forth so say for
example if we were expanding X plus 2 to
the 3rd what you do is you go down to
the 0 1 2 third row ok and what you do
is you take X okay to the third power
and this is your coefficient 1 and you
take 2 to the 0th power then you go to
the next one you say well this is 3 X to
the 2nd power
see how it's going down 2 to the first
power the second term is going into
ascending order then we take the next
coefficient 3 this is X to the first 2
to the second and then we go to the last
one we've got 1 X to the third and 2 to
the oops I said that wrong this is an X
to the 0 and we've got 2 to the third so
what you have is you have that first
term going down 3 2 1 0
you've got the second terms exponent
going up 0 1 2 3 and then you have the
coefficients which these coefficients by
the way are actually coming from 1 3 to
0 this is actually 3 choose 1 this is
actually 3 choose 2 and over here we
have 3 choose 3 now notice the pattern
see 3 choose 0 see how this is 0 and see
how the second terms exponent is 0 see
how this is 3 choose 1 and see how the
second term exponent is 1 3 choose 2 see
how this is exponents 2 and then also
notice about these powers 3 plus 0 is 3
and we're on the third row right where
the third power 2 plus 1 is 3 1 plus 2
is 3 see those exponents are adding up
to 3 so if you can see the pattern there
it's gonna make it a lot easier just to
jump to that specific term but also get
another example it says find the third
term in this expansion right here so we
don't want to foil this out 5 times
because we don't have time but what we
can do is we can say well we want the
third term we're on the fifth row so
this is going to be 5 shoes now remember
how this was like 3 choose 0 3 choose 1
3 choose 2 3 choose 3 when you do
Pascal's triangle it always starts off
with whatever role you're on choose 0 so
to get to the third term this is
actually gonna be 5 choose 2 because 5 -
0 5 choose 1 5 choose 2 that's actually
our third term and then we've got X
which is our first term in our binomial
positive 3y which is our second term and
remember how we said that this
value in this value are always the same
so if this is - this is - these two
powers add up to five so this must be
three so now we've been able to zero in
right on that third term without having
to do the whole expansion without having
to foil this out you know five of these
groups so that's how you zero in on this
and then basically what I'm going to do
is simplify so this is five factorial
over 5 minus 2 is 3 factorial 2
factorial X cubed 3 squared is 9 Y
squared ok so let's go to the calculator
to simplify that down a little bit 5
factorial is 120 divided by 3 factorial
which is 6 divided by another 2 factor
which is 2 seconds left - 10 so this
comes out to 90 X cubed Y squared so 90
you're following following along and
double check my work that's 90 X cubed Y
squared so if you need to go to my
channel go to binomial expansion theorem
or questions about binomial expansion
and you'll find more topics like this
but let's go on to the next question
okay if you're finding this beneficial
share it with a friend a classmate so
that they can boost their score on the
test as well but let's keep going with
this video it says if you score a
free-throw
80% of the time what is it probability
that you score exactly seven out of ten
free-throws
right so what they're testing us on in
this question is do we remember to
understand the binomial probability
theorem and what's the binomial
probability theorem well basically
binomial means that there's only two
things that can occur like you either
score the shot or you miss the shot
right you make the basket or you miss
the basket you win you lose success
failure right and so what we want to do
here is we want to figure out that out
of ten trials right ten you know shots
at the basket we want to score exactly
seven and the probability of scoring is
80% which is point eight zero and the
probability of missing is 20% and
there's three that we're going to to
miss so you would expand this out and
that's going to give you your
probability now if you want a formula
you can think of this as like this you
could say well this is the probability
of success let's call that P this is the
probability of failure which is 1 minus
P you know one is like a hundred percent
so if it's like 80 percent one minus
point eight that's 0.2 percent right
this is the number of
unless maybe let's call this case okay
is the number of successes n minus K is
the number of failures
okay and then here's a number of trials
and you want to score or in this case
you want K successes so it's easy to
remember you've got ten is the total and
this is how many you're scoring out of
that total so that's the probability of
scoring that's how many times you score
and then this is how many times you miss
which is that you know n minus K that's
the leftover right so if we simplify
this out let me go to the calculator on
this one so we've got let's see here
we've got 10 math it's choose seven
right and we've got point eight to the
seventh let's see and then times 0.2 to
the third right so I'm getting about
point two zero which means that it's
basically a 20% chance that you score
exactly seven okay so if it said you
know seven or more we'd have to
calculate it for seven eight nine and
ten and add all those probabilities
together okay if it's at seven or last
we could you know calculate zero one two
three four five six seven right so this
is binomial probability either you win
or you lose success failure two outcomes
so number four 18 I says given the
following quiz scores find the mean
median mode range standard deviation and
an outlier so here we're getting into
you know some statistics and basically
when you find the mean okay quick review
mean is the average so you add all these
up divided by how many you have right so
let's just do that real quick so we've
got let's see 10 plus let's see the 16
is 16 is 32 plus another 6 is 42 okay so
we've got like 52 divided by let's see
one two three four five six so divided
by six okay so it's about eight point
seven or so so that's your that's your
mean okay and then now let's see let's
see did I cut make a calculation error I
think I may have let me double check
again really quick so this is 10 plus 6
plus 16 plus 16 48 okay so 48 divided by
6 which is 8 okay so your mean is 8
that's your average right
the median is the one in the middle so
what you want to do is you want to count
towards the middle but in this case
notice how there's actually two that are
in the middle so what you want to do is
you want to add those up and divide by
two so we're an average the two middle
ones if it's a tie right so in this case
that's 14 divided by two is seven so our
median is seven the mode is the one that
occurs the most but in this case you can
see there's two fives and two eights so
we actually have two molds it's gonna be
five and also eight if they all just
occurred once and there'd be no mode if
there was let's say three eight then
eight would be the only mode you know
but you can have three modes for modes
but in this case there was just the two
modes five and eight and then the range
is the max minus the min so it'd be 16
minus 5 which is 11 that's our range and
then the outliner let's do that one next
outlier is the one that's either like
way to the right of all the data or way
below like rate you know a lot less than
all the rest of the data here it looks
like 16 is our outlier I'm just
eyeballing this particular one but
basically when you're given a set like
this use your teacher will give you one
that's way greater or way less than the
rest of the values and then the last
thing is the standard deviation now the
standard deviation you can do it on a
graphing calculator like the ti-83 or
ti-84 or some of the other calculators
out there but if your teacher has you do
it by hand let me just kind of show you
how you would make a table real quick
you would take your data points so X sub
I so this is going to be 5 5 6 8 8 and
16 right and then what you do is you
take your data point minus the mean okay
so the mean in this case was 8 so 5
minus 8 is going to give us negative 3 6
minus 8 is negative 2 0 and 16 minus 8
is 8 so I just took the data point minus
the mean that's what this X bar
represents then you take the deviation
okay so how far off it is from the mean
and you square it so negative 3 squared
is 9 negative 3 squared is 9 negative 2
squared is 4 0 squared of course is 0
and 8 squared is 64 and then what you do
is you add all these up okay so this is
the sum of the deviations squared okay
and then what you want to do is you want
to then divide that by the number of
data points and you want to take the
square root so that's our formula for
standard deviation so if we add these up
what do we get we get mmm excuse me 9
plus 9 is 18 plus 4 is 22
Plus 64 is 86 divided by let's see we
had six data points right that's
fourteen point three and we want to take
the square root of that comes out to
about three point eight so our standard
deviation is approximately three point
eight so that's how you do it by hand
okay and then Part B says you know if
the teacher gives everyone one extra
point say it's a you know difficult quiz
and they say we're gonna do an extra one
one point what's the new mean well the
new mean is just going to be eight plus
one it's just going to be nine now but
the standard deviation because we're
taking all these data points you're just
moving them one to the right standard
deviation gives you a sense of how
spread out or the dispersion of the data
in this case the amount they're spread
out by is not going to change at all
because we just add in one to each of
the data points so the standard
deviation is actually gonna stay the
same at three point eight so the key
here is if you were to multiply
everything by let's say your teacher
scale we're gonna give everybody an
additional ten percent so they
multiplied the scores by one point one
zero like one hundred and ten percent
what would happen then is the mean
median mode range standard deviation all
those who would be multiplied by one
point one zero but when you add you know
a data point like in this case we added
them one to each of the data points the
standard deviation and the range those
don't change those will give you an idea
about how spread out the data points are
those aren't going to change all the
other ones will change by just adding
that additional quantity to them okay so
that's the key there and then number
nineteen and we're getting into the
standard normal distribution curve here
okay this you learned about the standard
normal distribution curve and it says if
the average height of a student at your
school is five feet six inches with a
standard deviation of three inches what
is the probability that a randomly
selected student is over six feet tall
right so your teacher may have you
memorize this they may give you this
chart they also may give you a standard
normal table and you might have to use
the z-score now remember the z-score is
just the data point minus the mean over
the standard deviation and that tells
you how many standard deviations it's
above the mean okay or below the mean
okay so let's see if we can approach
this using the z-score formula so we've
got the data point which is 6 feet tall
okay
six feet tall which six feet is actually
what 72 inches right minus the mean okay
the mean is five feet six inches which
is how much that's sixty six inches okay
and divided by the standard deviation
which we said was three inches okay so
if we simplify this now we get 6 over 3
which is 2 that's our z-score and all
the z-score means is that we're two
standard deviations to the right so
we're going to be right here and we want
to know the probability that somebody
picked at random is over or greater than
six feet so you can see if we add up
these two regions here that's going to
give us 2.5%
so that's the percent chance that
somebody would be greater than six feet
tall at your particular school so again
you want to memorize the z-score formula
you may not want to memorize this this
table this graph here but let's go on to
the next question okay if you're
enjoying this subscribe to the channel
there's a lot more videos on my Mario's
mastering YouTube channel I've got
hundreds and hundreds of videos now on
there on all different aspects of math
so check that out but let's keep going
with this video it says if out of 200
students surveyed at your school 30
percent say that they bring their lunch
what is the margin of error of this
survey okay so you probably remember or
you need to review what's the formula
for the margin of error
well margin of error I'll just
abbreviate here equals plus or minus the
square root of 1 divided by n you want
to memorize that and as a number of
people surveyed so in this case what we
have is plus or minus the square root of
1 divided by 200 so I'm going to go to
the calculator now let's just see what
that comes out to you so we've got 1
divided by 200 and we're going to take
the square root of that answer and I get
0.07 okay but remember plus or minus you
want to move that decimal two places to
the right so this is going to be plus or
minus seven percent okay meaning that in
actuality it could actually be as high
as 37 percent or as low as 23 percent so
it's going to be in between those you
know in that interval in that range okay
of what the actual likely number of
students you know percentage of students
bring their lunch okay
so let's look at number 21 it says write
the first three terms of the sequence
now remember what's the difference
between a sequence in a series well
sequence is a list right so you're
listing off you know a list of numbers a
series of sum you're adding up all those
numbers together over those terms
together but here's a formula and
remember n is whatever term you're on so
if I put one in that's going to give me
the value of the first term so that's 3
over 1 plus 1 which is 2 so that's going
to be 3 halves if I put 2 in for the
second term that's going to be 3 over 3
which is 1 if I put 3 and that's gonna
be 3 over 4 which is 3/4 so just a quick
note about the notation C this is N
equals 1 N equals 2 N equals 3 dot dot
but this guy is actually a sub 1 that's
the value of the first term this is a
sub 2 value of the second term a sub 3
and so on
okay so just a little bit of a note
about the notation here it says write
the series using summation notation now
what's summation notation that's this a
weird-looking letter e here okay Sigma
and what you can see is we've got one
two three four five six terms so this is
our index I equals one to six
okay now what we need here is we need a
rule or a formula or an equation that
gives us the value of each of these
terms now what you might notice is that
it's going up by three each time that
means that it's arithmetic if you're
adding three each time or subtracting
the same thing each time and so a
formula you want to remember here is
this guy a sub N equals a sub one plus D
times n minus 1 a sub 1 is the first
term which is 5 the difference is what
we're adding so that's 3 and if I
simplify this down I get 5 plus 3 n
minus 3 5 minus 3 is 2 so I get 2 plus 3
3 n okay but what I was going to say is
we're using AI as our index so I'm going
to write this as 3i plus 2 so you want
to make sure these variables match so I
could use J I can use K I could use n
but in this case when I is 1 I put 1 in
here 3 times 1 is 3 plus 2 is 5 that
gives me the value there I put 2 in okay
that gets 6 plus 2 is 8 that gives me
this term and I work my way from 1 up to
6 and this just means that we're adding
or summing up all those together so this
is the formula okay or the writing the
series using summation notation or Sigma
notation okay so number 23 it says now
find the sum of the series now there's
formulas okay that you can use like if
we were going from you know one to a
hundred
you would definitely want to use an
equation or a formula to make this
simpler but when you only have a few
terms see we're going from a two to five
that's two three four five that's just a
few terms what I would do is I would
just put two in here two to the fourth
is 16 minus one is fifteen right then if
I put the next term working my way up to
5 3 is 81 minus one which is 80 let's
see what am I on now for 4 to the fourth
is 250 six minus one is 255 and then if
I put five in 5 to the 4th is 625 minus
1 is 624 all I have to do now is add
those together and that's the sum so
there's just a few terms like I said I
would just you know plug them in and add
them up okay so that comes out to 974 is
what I'm getting and that's the sum but
pretty easy for that problem okay number
24 it says write or rule for the nth
term of the sequence then find a sub 15
meaning the value of the fifteenth term
again the key is you got to figure out
what's the pattern is it arithmetic
meaning you're adding or subtracting the
same thing each time is a geometric
we're multiplying or dividing by the
same thing each time or is it something
altogether different here you can see
that we're subtracting 15 each time
right so that means it's arithmetic so
it means we're gonna be using the
equation we were using previously over
here which is this one right here so
it's the first term which is 100 all
right we're adding a negative 15 n minus
1 times okay so let's see so if we
simplify this down we get negative 15 n
plus 15 I'm just distributing add the
hundred so that's going to be negative
15 negative 15 n plus 115 okay so that's
our rule or our equation or our formula
for finding a value of any term in the
sequence this list but now we want to
find the fifteenth term so we don't
necessarily want to do this recursively
you know find a fifteenth term we want
to use this explicit formula and we're
just gonna put 15 in here so we get
negative 225 plus 115 which is how much
negative 110 right and that's going to
be the value of the fifteenth term okay
number 25 says write or rule for the nth
term of the arithmetic sequence given
that
seventh term is 12 and the common
difference is negative three okay so
basically we've been doing a lot of
problems with arithmetic sequence is
arithmetic just means you're adding or
subtracting get to the next term but
what we're going to do is we're going to
start off with the formula the explicit
formula for an arithmetic sequence which
is this guy right here now what's
interesting is they're telling us what
the common difference is it's negative
three they're telling us that the value
of the seven terms see how that's I'm
putting seven in for n that's the term
number that we're on we don't know the
first term but we know the value of the
seventh term is 12 so all I did is I
substituted in what we know and what
we're gonna do is we're gonna solve for
that first term so I'm going to
distribute the negative three let's see
well actually I'll just simplify this
the 7 minus 1 is 6 times negative 3 is
negative 18 right and then you can see
if we add 18 to the other side that
means that the first term is equal to 30
so now if we put it all back together
and using the same formula again right
we know that the first term is equal to
30 and we're going down by negative 3
each time so negative 3 times n minus 1
now if we distribute the negative 3 just
to kind of condense this down a little
bit what you can see is we've got 33
minus 3 N equals a sub N and you can
check your work like say for example if
I put 7 in that's going to be 33 minus
21 which is 12 that makes sense you know
and you can test it out but you can see
this is just like the equation of a line
we're going down by negative 3 each time
so that's like your slope okay now
number 26 it says write or rule for the
nth term of the sequence and find the
value of the eighth term okay now what
you might notice here is that what are
we doing to get to the next term are we
adding the same thing each time are we
you know subtracting dividing
multiplying or is it some other pattern
altogether well here what you can see is
we're actually dividing by 3 but
remember division is like multiplying by
the reciprocal so we're actually
multiplying by 1/3 and when you work
with them multiplying and dividing you
take it to the next term those are
called geometric sequences and the
formula you want to memorize or remember
or learn if you're just getting into
this is this guy right here it's a sub 1
that's the value of your first term
times your ratio to the N minus 1 power
so
this case our first term is 12 our ratio
meaning what we're multiplying by is
one-third to the N minus one power so
that's our rule right there now why do
they call it a ratio well they call it a
ratio because if you take 4 divided by
12 that's 1/3 or 4/3 divided by 4 if you
take the term divided by the one before
it as a ratio that's what you're
multiplying by to get to the next term
ok but now if we want to find the eighth
term all I have to do is put in 8 for n
so that's going to give us a sub 8
equals 12 times 1/3 to the 8 minus 1
which is 7 and you can simplify that
I'll let you do that I'm you're all ok
number 27 it says given a geometric
sequence with the value of the third
term is 8 and the ratio is 1/2 write a
rule for the nth term ok so what they're
doing is again they're having us work
with this formula ok and I'll just write
it down here again but they're giving us
some interesting information they're
telling us that hmm the value of the
third term is 8 right the common ratio
is 1/2 the value of that third terms
that's 3 minus 1 which is 2 now the only
thing we're missing is the value of the
first term so 1/2 squared we know is 1/4
so this is going to be 1/4 a sub 1
equals 8 if we multiply both sides by 4
you can see the 4 on the 1/4 cancel and
give us a 1 equals 32 so if we put it
all back together we get a sub N equals
32 times 1/2 to the n minus 1 and that's
going to be a rule for any term in the
geometric sequence okay so now going
over to number 28 it says find the sum
of the geometric series so remember
series means that you're adding the
terms together sequence is just a list
series as a sum and this is like a
condensed way of writing the the series
using the summation notation or the
Sigma notation but the formula we want
to know here or you want to remember is
this guy it's a sub 1 1 minus R to the N
all over 1 minus R ok now in this case
we're trying to find the sum of the
first 10 terms okay so what we're going
to do is we're going to take the first
term which is okay if we put 1 in we get
1 minus 1 is 0 2 to the 0 is 1 times 3
is 3 so we know the value of the first
term is 3 the ratio is what we're
multiplying by we're multiplying by 2
each time
and as the number of terms there's ten
terms although I'd buy one - the ratio
which is two now how did I know that the
this was a geometric well first of all
they told us second of all it fits this
form a one R to the N minus 1 ok so that
explicit formula the explicit rule for a
geometric sequence so you can see your
first term you can see your ratio but it
doesn't hurt to test by putting in a few
values to make sure that you you know
you're working with the geometric so
let's simplify here a little bit so
we've got 1 minus 2 is a negative 1 now
what you want to remember you when you
do this when I do your order of
operations you want to do the
parentheses exponents you know so I work
from the inside out or you can put it
all in your calculator just make sure to
put parentheses around the denominator
in the numerator and so you know you
treat it as a group but what I'm gonna
do here is I'm gonna say let's see 1
minus 2 to the 10th okay that comes out
to negative 1023 okay negative 1,000 23
these two negatives are gonna cancel
give us a positive so that's going to
come out to what 3069 and that's going
to be the sum of the first 10 terms so
it saves you from having to put in 1 2 3
up to 10 and then adding those together
so this is if it's a finite geometric
series meaning there's a fixed number of
terms not an infinite number of terms
but a number 29 notice how it says find
the sum of this series and you see the
dot dot dot the ellipsis that means it
keeps going right forever so this one is
an infinite geometric series and the
form you want to use here is this guy a
1 over 1 minus R okay but this formula
only works if the ratio is in between
negative 1 and 1 because then it will
get smaller and smaller it will converge
to 0 okay and then you'll be able to add
up all those terms if the ratio is 2 if
you kept doubling for example it would
go to infinity and you can't find that
sum it would be an infinite sum so here
what we're gonna do is we see the first
term is a hundred so that's a sub one
okay the ratio is what we're multiplying
by we keep multiplying by 1/2 so this is
going to be 1 minus 1/2 and you can see
1 minus 1/2 is 1/2 when we take 100
divided by 1/2 we get 200 and you can
kind of see this is approaching 200 150
175 180 7.5 is gradually getting closer
and closer to that
of 200 okay question number 30 we're
moving on into the trigonometry part of
this course and you know it's talking
about evaluate without a calculator
you know all these angles some are in
degrees some are in radians and what you
really want to review here is the unit
circle so I've got you know a couple of
different videos on my Margo's math
tutor and YouTube channel talking about
how to master the unit circle and how to
work with the unit circle but the key
thing is to really know your reference
angles your 30 or 45 or 60 if you know
those and you know these coordinates
that's a big part of finding out all
these values so let's see if we can work
through these fairly quickly but just
kind of going through it sine of 30
remember on the unit circle the sine is
the y-coordinate the cosine is the ax
tangent is y over X once we find the
sine cosine tangent of course we can
take the reciprocal to get the
reciprocal trig functions like the
cosecant secant cotangent right so let's
see so sine of 30 degrees here's 30
degrees sine is the Y value that's going
to be one half okay so that one was easy
now cosine of 5 PI over 6 now we're
talking radians remember pi is 180
radians so this is 180 divided by 6 is
30 times 5 is 150 or if you're used to
thinking in terms of radians we're going
to be over here at 5 PI over 6 notice
that this is a 30 degree reference angle
which is the same as this 30 degree
reference angle but because we're in the
second quadrant the x coordinate is
going to be negative the Y coordinates
still going to be positive we're finding
cosine cosine is the x coordinate so you
can see it's going to be negative square
root 3 over 2 okay now the tangent of
negative 3 PI over 4 remember when it's
a positive angle you're going
counterclockwise negative angle you're
going clockwise 3 PI over 4 is 3/4 of Pi
or 3/4 of 180 which is going to put you
right here you always want to drop a
perpendicular to the x-axis that gives
you a reference angle of 45 degrees
which means it's gonna have the same
coordinates as this 45 degree angle but
because you're in the 3rd quadrant and
you're going left and down these are
both going to be negative so negative
root 2 over 2 negative root 2 over 2 at
this point tangent remember is the Y
over the X so Y divided by X anything
divided by itself is 1 so this is just
going to be 1 cosecant of 2/10 let's see
so where is 2/10 we go 90 180 30 more so
that's going to be right here
again you can see that reference angle
to the X
this is a 30 degree reference angle
meaning it has the same coordinates as
these two guys here but they're both
going to be negative so we have negative
root 3 over 2 negative 1/2 cosecant is
the reciprocal of sine remember sine is
the y-coordinate so that's negative 1/2
we flip that over we're gonna get
negative 2 secant of 7 PI over 6 7 PI
over 6 is actually the same as 2/10 so
we're actually in the same location
right here ok and the secret remember is
the reciprocal of cosine which is in
this case the reciprocal of the
x-coordinate because cosine is the ax so
if I flip this over I get negative 2
over root 3 but remember we don't want
the squared in the denominator so we
have to rationalize so this gives us
negative 2 or 3 over 3 and then the last
one cotangent of pi C pi is 180 degrees
we end up right here at negative 1 0
cotangent is a reciprocal of tangent so
tangent is y over X that's 0 over
negative 1 cotangent is x over Y that's
negative 1 over 0 but we can't divide by
0 so this is undefined so review the
unit circle if you need to it's very
important of course and you can check
out some of those videos I did on my
Amaro's math tutoring youtube channel
but number 31 it says evaluate the six
trig functions given this triangle okay
so this is right triangle trigonometry
the key though here is we have to find
this missing side using our Pythagorean
theorem right
a squared plus B squared equals C
squared so C is the longest side across
from the right angle that's 25 a squared
is going to be 2 squared which is 4 if
we subtract 4 from both sides we get 21
take the square root you can see B is
going to be the square root of 21 all
right
so now if we do the sine I'm just going
to be using the sohcahtoa acronym that
we talked about before so
to-- all right so is the sine it cause
the cosine 2 Toa is the tangent remember
it's always the second over the third
that's that's the nice thing about this
acronym sine is the opposite over the
hypotenuse cosine is the adjacent over
the hypotenuse tangent the opposite over
the adjacent side okay so sine means
we're standing over here at the angle
okay sine is the opposite over the
hypotenuse so that's 2 over 5 cosecant
is the reciprocal of science and I just
flipped that over 5 over 2 cosine is the
adjacent over hypotenuse adjacent means
next to root 21 over 5 right
over five secant is the reciprocal of
cosine so I just flipped that over but
we don't want the radical in the
denominator so I have to rationalize so
that's five or 21 over 21 the tangent of
course is opposite over adjacent that's
2 over 21 coach and since reciprocals if
I flip that over
but for this tangent one I don't want
the radical in the denominator so again
I have to rationalize so that's
something to pay attention to if you get
that square root in the denominator now
for 32 it says solve this triangle now
what does that mean solve solve the
triangle
well it means find all the angles and
all the sides in this case the only
thing that we're missing our this angle
here and then these two side lengths now
all the angles in a triangle add up to
how much 180 right but if this angle is
90 that means these two have to add up
to 90 they're complementary which means
that this angle here must be how much is
that 68 degrees yeah 68 because that's
going to be 80 plus 2 is 90 so 68
degrees is angle Y ok and then let's see
we want to find a length of Y Z right
here I always like to go back to the
original information if possible so if
I'm solving for this so I'll just call
the side X here this is sine of 22
degrees well that's not actually sine is
it it's the opposite and this is
adjacent so that's tangent tangent of 22
is equal to x over 10 multiply both
sides by 10 and you can see X as 10
times the tangent of 22 so let's go to
the calculator and see what that comes
out to and you can check me on this here
I'm getting about 4 point about 4.0 I'm
just going to say about 4 okay and then
over here XY that's this length here we
were doing let's see adjacent and
hypotenuse that's cosine so we're going
to say that cosine of 22 degrees equals
10 over I'll just call this side over
here Y and so then what we can do is we
can cross multiply that's going to be Y
times the cosine of 22 evils 10 times 1
and then divide both sides by cosine of
22 so what does that come out to let's
see we've got 10.8 approximately if we
round so that's the key with solving the
triangle you're trying to find all the
angles all the sides you're using your
sine cosine tangent ratios and you've
got it
okay cruising right along number 3
three it says find the angle of
depression from the balloon to the
person so this is like a hot-air balloon
here's a person down on the ground now
there's some little bit of maybe you
don't want a micro analyze this too much
but basically if we work with the
diagram that they're giving us here you
know as it to the person's feet is it to
the person's head is it from the bottom
of this basket but let's just work with
the diagram here what they're testing us
on is you know how do we find the angle
of depression where is that angle of
depression and then you know how do we
solve for the missing angle so the key
thing here when you're doing Ingle
depression see angle of elevation is a
you elevator you look up okay from the
horizontal so this is the angle of
elevation like that depression you look
down from the horizontal okay so you're
with me there so here if this is the
person in the balloon okay we have to
draw in this auxilary line like that
depression is down from the horizontal
that's saying we want right there but
notice what we can do here we can
actually make this into a rectangle this
is the angle of elevation that's from
this person's perspective looking up
towards the bottom of that balloon but
notice that this is a thousand this is a
thousand if this is three thousand this
is three thousand and if this angle and
this angle I'll just call this theta
these are exactly the same because
they're alternate interior angles notice
that these two lines are parallel cut by
a transversal like that right okay so
remember your alternate interior angles
from geometry okay so now here's the key
we can see this as a right angle okay we
have to ask for solve what trig function
ties together opposite and adjacent well
that's tangent write sohcahtoa remember
but whenever you're solving for the
missing angle you want to use the
inverse sine or inverse cosine or
inverse tangent to find the missing
angle so that's the key so I'm gonna do
the tangent inverse of opposite over
adjacent okay if we go to the calculator
what does that come out to let's see hmm
tangent inverse of 1,000 divided by
3,000 okay which is about eighteen point
four degrees so that's the angle of
depression right there eighteen point
four degrees okay so number 34 it says
give one positive angle and one negative
angle coterminal with PI over five now
what does coterminal mean KO means same
terminal means where it terminates okay
so if you think about this PI over five
is right about not
maybe about here so okay but if you
think of it an angle is like a spinner
like you know if I spin this no matter
how many times it goes around this
direction or this direction if it ends
up or terminates in the same spot then
those angles are coterminal mean they
terminate at the same spot so the key
here when you're working with radians if
you add 2 pi that's like going around
360 degrees you end up in the same spot
or if you subtract 2 pi then you're
going this direction you're gonna end up
in the same spot okay but the key here
is we have to get common denominators so
if I multiply by 5 over 5 that gives me
10 PI over 5 plus 1 PI over 5 there's 11
PI over 5 here if I subtract 1 PI over 5
minus 10 PI over 5 is negative 9 PI over
5 now just a word of advice you know is
that sometimes what happens is you may
subtract 2 pi and you still have a
positive angle but your teacher says
find a positive in a negative angle so
you might have to subtract 2 pi multiple
times until you get to a negative angle
okay same thing with the positive angle
you might have to add 2 pi 2 pi 2 pi now
if it's in degrees you would just add
360 and subtract 360 but you might again
have to add 360 multiple times subtract
360 multiple times okay number 35 we're
converting from radians to degrees
degrees to radians now the key to this
conversion is really recognizing or
remembering or knowing however you want
to say it that 180 degrees is equivalent
to PI radians now how did I know how to
set it up like this well I want to make
sure that the PI's cancel numerator and
denominator and I end up with the unit's
which I want which are the degrees right
see I circled that little degree symbol
so now what we can do is we can multiply
the numerators and denominators okay and
reduce or we can do something called
cross canceling okay 9 goes in here once
mangoes in here 25 times 20 gives us 100
degrees now for going from degrees to
radians it's almost the exact same thing
but now I'm going to be multiplying by
PI over 180 notice that the degrees
units cancel numerator and denominator
and we end up with the PI radians so if
I multiply the numerators across like
you know this way horizontally we get
105 PI over 1 times 180 is 180 and then
you can reduce this down a little bit
more so let me see if I can just go to
the calculator reduce that
just to do that for us so let's see that
comes out to 7 PI over 12 7 PI over 12
so you can just reduce these numbers and
then add the PI in there so that's an
exact angle in radians okay so now our
36 we're going to finding the arc length
okay which is this length here and we're
finding the area of the sector that's
the area of that shaded region now
there's a couple different ways to do
this problem I'll try to see if I can
explain both ways to you depending on
how your teacher wants you to do it one
way is to use these formulas s equals R
theta an area of the sector is one-half
R squared theta so s represents this arc
length okay and a represents the area of
this sector now to use these two
formulas theta the central angle has to
be in Radian so if they give it to you
in degrees you can use these techniques
we just did to convert it into radians
then go ahead and use these two formulas
the other way to do this is to think
about it as a proportion you can say
well hmm 2 PI over 3 right is 2 2 pi see
like the 2 PI over 3 is 2 the whole you
know circle 360 degrees or 2 pi radians
and as the arc length I'll just call
that s is 2 the entire circumference
which is what 2 pi times 4 okay so
that's one way to do is set up as a
proportion part to the whole equals part
to the whole and cross multiply
but these formulas are pretty quick you
know because if you already have the
angle and radians you just have to say
oh that's the radius of 4 times 2 PI
over 3 okay so that means that the arc
length is going to be 8 PI over 3 inches
so you done right now with the area the
sector you can do the exact same thing
you can make a proportion you could say
2 PI over 3 is 2 2 pi C the central
angle 2 PI over 3 is 2 the whole circle
2 pi as the area of the sector we'll
just call this a here is 2 the area of
the entire circle which is PI R squared
so pi times 4 squared cross multiply and
solve but if you want to use these
foremost here again remember theta has
to be in radians so we're just going to
do hmm let's see 1/2 the radius square
root of 16 a central angle is 2 PI over
3 right and so if you multiply let's see
across this is going to be 32 PI over 6
divide these both by 2
that's 16 PI over 3 inches squared since
its area and you've got the area of that
sector okay question number 37 it says
evaluate no calculator the sine inverse
cosine inverse tangent inverse now the
key thing with this problem is when you
do the inverse trig functions you want
to remember that when you're finding the
sine inverse or the tangent inverse the
restricted domain is from negative PI
over 2 to positive PI over 2 and when
you do the cosine inverse the restricted
domain is from 0 to PI so that's the key
thing sine inverse and tangent versus
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
cosine versus 0 to PI so here what this
is asking us is it's like a Jeopardy
question they give us the answer
negative 1 its sine of what angle equals
negative 1 on this restricted domain
well hmm sine is negative 1 right here
some students make the mistake of saying
270 degrees this is actually a negative
90 degrees or if you want to use radians
you could say negative PI over 2
for this one the cosine inverse of
negative root 3 over 2 we go to our
cosine restricted domain here and
whereas cosine negative root 3 over 2
that's going to be right here and that's
going to be at 5 PI over 6 ok now the
thing is this cosine is negative root 3
over 2 here as well but you can see it's
not in the restricted domain right and
then the last one where does tangent
equal negative root 3 again that's in
between negative 90 and positive 90 or
negative PI over 2 to positive PI over 2
and remember tangent to the Y over X so
here we're actually looking at a 60
degree reference angle at this point is
one half negative root 3 over 2 but
remember tangent is y over X so if you
take negative root 3 over 2 over 1/2 C
the twos cancel and you get native root
3 so this is going to be a negative 60
degree angle or you could say negative
PI over 3 again you want to pay
attention to those restricted domains ok
number 38 says solve triangle a CT ok
like the a CT right test and they give
us similar information so let's just
kind of draw a generic triangle here's
angle a here's angle C here's angle T
across from angle a that's side a right
across from angle T that's side T and
across from angle C that's you know side
C right so let's see so what do we have
T is equal to 6
to degrees angle a is equal to 48
degrees and side C we know is 12 okay
now if we add up these angles all the
angles add up to 180 degrees so this is
what this is a hundred and ten which
means that this angle must be seventy so
now what we have here is we can actually
notice it's not a right triangle so we
can't use our sohcahtoa or right
triangle trigger testing us on here are
the law of sines law of cosines as it
applies to any renown right triangles
right of course you can use it for any
trial a right triangle but it's most
useful when you have a non right
triangle so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take the sine of 62 degrees
over its side opposite which is T equals
the sine of 70 degrees over its side
opposite which is 12 so you make a
proportion do sine of the angle over its
side opposite equals a sine of the angle
over its side opposite and then what you
can do is you can cross multiply so I've
got 12 times the sine of 62 degrees
equals T times the sine of 70 degrees
and then what we just have to do is
divide both sides by sine of 70 sine of
70 and let's see what that comes out to
you so we've got hmm 12 sine of 60 -
let's see / sine of 70 all right I'm
getting about eleven point three I'm
just rounding okay so we'll just say T
is eleven point three eleven point three
now all we have to do is solve for this
side here a and I'm gonna do the same
proportion we did over here I'm going to
say sine of 70 over twelve equals sine
of forty eight over a I'm gonna cross
multiply and solve I'll just do that on
the calculator a real quick here so
twelve you can check my work sine of 48
okay divided by sine of 70 cross
multiplying and dividing so I'm getting
nine point five approximately and so
that's it so you solve the triangle by
finding all the angles all the sides but
what we had to do here was use the law
of sines now for number thirty-nine it's
a solved triangle SAT okay like the SAT
test so here we did a CT here we're
doing SAT right so here is angle s a T
now notice I'm using capital letters for
the angles that's the normal way that
they do it the dick normal convention
but across from the angle is the side
and use a lowercase letter for the
excuse me for the side so we've got s
equals five
I equals six and T equals seven okay so
now what we're doing is we need to solve
for the missing angles so basically when
they give you either three sides like
side side side or they give you side
angle side like the angle in between two
sides you have to use law of cosines if
you use the law of sines you're gonna
have too many variables you won't be
able to solve the triangle so here what
we're really using is we're using the
law of cosines which is this formula
here C squared equals a squared plus B
squared minus 2a B cosine C okay but in
this case I'm going to solve for angle s
first so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to treat these two sides like my
to say my a maybe I'm going to treat my
angle asked like my angle C and I'm
gonna be solving for the side s okay I'm
sorry I'm sure I'm gonna be solving for
the angle s and I know the side s so if
I put this in I get five squared equals
six squared plus seven squared minus two
times six times seven times the cosine
of angle s so our goal here is to get
this by itself take the cosine inverse
and solve for angle s okay so if I do
that that's going to be 25 equals 36
plus 49 minus let's see that's 84 cosine
ass a lot of times students make the
mistake of trying to combine all these
together but see how the 84 is
multiplied by the cosine of s so what we
really want to do is add these together
and subtract it from the 25 so I'm just
going to use the calculator here so 25
I'm going to subtract the 36 I'm going
to subtract the 49 so I'm getting a
negative 60 equals a negative 84 cosine
s I'm going to divide both sides by
negative 84 because we want to get
cosine C by itself and then what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna take the cosine
inverse of both sides to solve for angle
C so let me go ahead and do that let's
see what does that come out to I'm
getting forty four point four degrees
I'm just gonna round to the nearest
degree just to keep this simple for this
example cosine s okay so s angle s is
equal to 44 degrees approximately okay
now once you do the law of sines the
nice thing about it is you only have to
do it once you can switch over the law
of cosines now so law of sines now I'm
sorry we did a lot of cosines don't have
to do that once the law of sines now you
can switch over to so sine of 40
or over the side opposite which is five
equals the sine of angle T over its side
opposite which is seven okay so I'm
going to multiply both sides by seven
I'm going to do this I'm going to take
the sine inverse right to get the
missing angle here so seven sine of 44 K
divided by five take the sine inverse of
that answer and we're getting 77 I'm
rounding to the nearest degrees so this
is going to be T equals 77 degrees now
if you add these up all the angles have
to add up to 180 so if I take 77 plus 44
and I take that away from one night 180
we get 59 degrees so you solved a
triangle you found all the angles you
found all the sides and again what you
want to do is review the law of sines
and law of cosines and I have more
videos on that on my youtube channel
Mira's math tutoring if you want to
review this in a little bit more detail
than we did here we're kind of trying to
go through a lot of concepts fairly
quickly to help you get up to speed for
your exam but if you're enjoying this
video so far and you like my teaching
style and you are preparing for the ECT
and the SAT the math sections check out
my two huge review courses my two huge
math review for course is one for the AC
t-- math section one for the SAT math
section I go through a teaching section
I go through example problems I go
through formulas I go through ways to
recognize and approach the different
problems so when you take the tests
you're able to score higher you know
increase your speed increase your
efficiency increase your accuracy so
check out the three free lessons that I
have available through the link on the
interactive card and take those the
lessons you'll definitely benefit from
those and then you can decide whether
you want to go on and take the rest of
the course a lot of students like I said
I've taken it and boosted their scores
I'm sure you will too
and if you're interested in private
one-on-one online tutoring with me you
can also contact me I've got a link in
the description through my website Myers
math tutoring com or there's a link in
my about page if you want to reach out
to me and talk to me about any type of
tutoring whether it's for the AC T SAT
or you know your exam review or just
your class in general let me know if I
can help you but let's continue on with
this video and get you up to speed for
your algebra two final exam okay is
everybody hanging in there we're getting
near the end of
video and covering some really important
concepts so this one says find the area
of triangle d EF ok so I like to call
this formula the side-angle-side
area formula because they're giving you
side angle inside the angle in between
the two sides and you can think of this
formula like this like 1/2 a B sine C or
1/2 B C sine a or you could say 1/2 AC
sine angle B however you want to think
about it you take 1/2 times the two
sides multiplied together so 9 and 6 and
then you take the sine of the included
angle that's the angle that's in between
those two sides now if you forget that
formula what a lot of students will do
is a little drop in altitude like this
ignore the 6 for a moment and just call
this H you could do the sine of 63
equals H over 9 you could solve for that
height then just go ahead and use your
form in the area equals 1/2 base times
height okay so either way I kind of like
this formula but sometimes it's just
easier to drop an altitude let's
calculate what this is in case you're
wondering what that answer is so it
times the sine of 63 right so I'm
getting about 24 point one ok units
squared for the area now this one over
here Part B it says find the area of
triangle GHI this is what I like to call
the side side side area formula or what
you can do is you can use herons area
formula Heron or hero depending on how
that you want to pronounce that but
basically the formula here for Heron's
formula when you find the area and
you're given three sides ok side side
side is you find what's called the
semi-perimeter what's the semi-perimeter
it's just like it sounds it's semi
meaning half the perimeter you add up
all three sides you divide by 2 and then
you take that semi perimeter and then
the semi-perimeter minus each side in
turn you multiply all those together and
take the square root and that gives you
the area of the triangle so it's a kind
of a neat quick efficient formula when
you're given just three sides so let's
figure out what is that semi perimeter
well if we add up the sides we get 18 so
that's the perimeter divided by 2 is 9
so in this case our semi perimeter is 9
9 minus 7 is 2 9 minus 6 is 3 and 9
minus 5 is 4 3 multi-levels together and
take the
square-root we've got it so let's see
what does that come out to let's let's
see that six let's see it maybe do this
a little bit different way so we've got
here I'll use the calculator so we've
got 18 times 12 right 18 times 12 216
and if you take the square root of 216
you could simplify this because this is
really equal to 36 times 6 which is 6
squared is 6 and that's going to give
you an exact answer 6 square root of 6
units squared okay so that's Heron's
formula so another number 41 and 42 and
in going on we're talking about graphing
these trig functions sine cosine tangent
etc so the first one here they're
basically asking us to graph the sine
graph now notice this number in front
okay this is the amplitude so we're
gonna say a equals to the period okay is
related to this B value this number
that's in front of the ax so remember
the period is what I said I can fit it
in over here a period is equal to 2 pi
divided by B so the normal period for
sine is 2 pi 2 pi divided by 1/2 is
going to give us a period of 4 pi so
what you can do is you can divide this
up into 4 pieces there's your period for
pi and our scale is gonna be counting by
by PI's okay now let me see I'll label
this one and 2 3 negative 1 negative 2
negative 3 right now let's see if we can
graph this so sine it starts at the
midline it goes up to the maximum which
in this case is 2 back to the midline
back down to the minimum back to the
midline so it goes 0 max 0 men 0 match
like that it alternates the domain is
what the x-values can be so this keeps
repeating so it's going to the left and
the right okay so the domain is going to
be all real numbers or you could say
negative infinity to positive int if you
want to use interval notation the range
is going to be what the y-values are you
can see this is going to be from
negative 2 to positive 2 and I'm using
the brackets because it includes a
negative 2 all the way up to including
positive 2 okay so for number 42 now
we're graphing a cosine graph now
there's a little bit more going on with
this equation here you can see the
amplitude is 1/2 here you can see the
period is 2 pi divided by 4 which is
giving us high over two for our period
so let's see if we can divide this up so
here's a period of PI over 2 if I divide
that
for I'm getting a scale of PI over eight
so that's two PI over eight which is PI
over 4 3 PI over 8 4 PI over 8 right and
then we can continue to go this
direction as well so this is what
negative PI over 8 negative PI over 4
negative 3 PI over 8 and so on the phase
shift is this one group here with the X
that's what shifts the graph left and
right so this one the X plus PI over 4
is actually shifting it the opposite
it's actually shifting at left PI over 4
or you could just say left PI over 4 the
vertical shift is this guy over here
this is shifting it up and down so in
this case minus 1 is shifting it down so
I'm gonna say negative 1 so what I like
to do is I like to go like this I like
to say okay say here's negative 1 here's
positive 1 it's shifting down 1 so I'm
gonna draw in this like dashed or dotted
line okay and it's shifting left PI over
4 which is right here so I'm going to
kind of draw in this dotted line so we
can think of this as our starting point
ok instead of this as their origin we
can think of this as our origin and then
what we're doing now is our amplitude is
1/2 cosine starts at the maximum so
that's gonna start right here at 1/2
okay then it's going to go down to the 0
and then let's put this as negative 2
down here so then it's going to go down
to the minimum back to the 0 back to the
maximum so you can see my amplitude here
is 1/2 and it repeats okay so for this
one the domain is going to be all real
numbers just like for sine so from
negative infinity to positive infinity
but the range is going from negative
three-halves to negative 1/2 so negative
three-halves to negative 1/2 so that's
your your y-values so if you need to go
ahead and go back to my Mara's math
you're in YouTube channel to review
graphing sines and cosines but this is
your basic formula right here that you
want to become familiar with a for
amplitude B is related to the period by
2 PI over B H is the phase shift and K
is the vertical shift and then just
familiar so familiarize yourself with
the basic graphs and then you can do
these transformations but let's go on to
the neck okay question number 43 it says
y equals two tangent one-half X and what
we want to do is we want to list the
period the domain the range and we
graphic okay so what we're gonna do in
this problem is we're just going to do a
quick review of how to graph tangent now
remember from your unit circle we're
going to look at these points here zero
negative one zero positive one one zero
and then these ones at the 45 these are
going to be root 2 over 2 and negative
root 2 over 2 and then this one's going
to be both paws over 2 over 2 positive
root 2 over 2 like that so the tangent
you calculate the tangent on the unit
circle it's the Y value divided by the x
value Y divided by X Y divided by X and
so on so if we were to graph our basic
tangent graph at negative PI over 2
negative 1 divided by 0 is how much well
since we can't divide by 0 we're
actually going to get a vertical
asymptote and then at negative PI over 4
okay so right here Y divided by X is
going to be negative 1 okay so that's
going to be right here and then Y
divided by X at 0 degrees that's going
to be 0 and then at positive PI over 4
that's going to be Y divided by X which
is positive 1 and then at PI over 2 1
divided by 0 is undefined again so we're
gonna get another vertical asymptote and
so our graphs gonna look something like
this and it's going to repeat ok but in
this case because we have a 2 here what
it's gonna do is gonna multiply the Y
values by 2 so it's a vertical stretch
and this period is gonna change so this
1/2 what it does is you can use this
form the for tangent period equals pi
divided by B this is our B value right
here so if we do pi divided by 1/2 that
gives us a period of 2pi so let's put
that in here two PI's if I was going to
graph this what I would do is I would
take the 2 pi I would cut it in half
since half the graph you can see is to
the right of the y-axis half is to the
left of the y-axis that's where our
asymptotes are going to be our vertical
asymptotes and then if you take these
Midway points see half of Pi is PI over
2 or in this case on the left side
negative PI over 2 then what we're going
to do is we're going to look at this a
value two that's going to stretch it so
we're going to be over here at positive
two and we're going to be down here at
negative two and it goes right through
the origin so these are some easy to
graph points like that so now if we want
to look at the domain domain is whatever
the X values can be right so the domain
is all real numbers except for where
these asymptotes
sigh right so I'm just going to write
over here all reals but X cannot equal
PI plus multiples of 2/pi so meaning if
ret PI
we had another two pi that puts at us at
3 pi which is where the next vertical
asymptote is and so on and then the
range is the Y values you can see this
is going down toward the negative
infinity up towards positive infinity it
contains all real numbers so that's how
you would do that one so let's go to the
next question number 44 it says given
that cosine of theta equals 3/5 and
theta is in between 3 PI over 2 to 2 pi
find the sine of theta ok so what I like
to do on problems like this is just draw
a quick sketch 3 PI over 2 is over here
2 pi is over here right so what I would
do is I would draw this triangle in the
fourth quadrant ok and we can see that
cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse and
if we do the Pythagorean theorem we get
4 for this missing side but it's going
to be negative 4 since we're going down
okay
so now if we want to find the sine of
theta all we have to do is instead of
doing cosine which is adjacent
hypotenuse we just have to do sine is
opposite over hypotenuse so that's going
to be negative 4/5 so the easiest way to
do that when it's just to graph it okay
now number 45 it asks us to simplify
these so here we're getting into the
trig identities okay and so basically
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to take cosecant of X which is 1 over
sine of X tangent of X which is equal to
sine of X over cosine of X and then
cosine of X which you can really think
of as divided by 1 because I think
divided by 1 is itself right so now what
we can do is you can see that the sine
of X are gonna cancel numerator
denominator same thing with the cosines
so we end up with 1 over 1 which is just
equal to 1 so that condenses down very
nicely for Part B here we've got sine
squared plus cosine squared if you
remember your Pythagorean trig
identities that's going to be equal to 1
okay over sine of X but remember the
reciprocal of sine is cosecant so this
whole thing is going to condense down to
cosecant of X okay question number 46
it says solving the interval from 0 to
2pi this equation 2 sine squared X
equals 1 ok so what we want to do here
is it's just like solving an algebra
equation
you want to get that trig function by
itself instead of the variable by itself
so I'm going to do is I'm going to
divide both sides by two so that gives
us sine square root of x equals one half
I'm going to take the square root of
both sides to get just that sine by
itself so sine of x equals plus or minus
square root of 1 over square root of 2
and then you know square root of 1 is
just 1 but if you rationalize this by
multiplying by square root of 2 over
square root of 2 we get sine of x equals
plus or minus square root 2 over 2 so
what you want to do now is you want to
go to the unit circle and you want to
say to yourself well where to sine equal
positive root 2 over 2 or negative root
2 over 2 and you can see that that's
going to be at these 45 degree angles
these PI over 4 angles okay
so basically what we have here is we've
got the final answer is going to be PI
over 4 3 PI over 4 5 PI over 4 and 7 PI
over 4 so at all four of those 45 so
this is just once around the unit circle
from 0 to 2 pi now for Part B it says
three tangent of X minus square root of
3 equals 0 same idea I want to get that
tangent by itself so I'm going to add
the square root of 3 to the other side
ok and then what I'm going to do is
going to divide both sides by 3 because
we want to get that tangent by itself
okay and so then what we have is where
does tangent of X equals square root of
3 over 3 so again you really want to be
familiar with your unit circle
remember tangents the Y over the X so is
that going to be at a 30 degree
reference angle as you're going to be at
a 60 degree reference angle well let's
take a look so at 30 degrees this is
going to be square root 3 over 2 comma
1/2 okay and remember at tangent is y
over X so if we take 1/2 divided by
square root 3 over 2 if you multiply the
numerator and denominator by 2 you can
see how that gives you 1 over square
root of 3 and if then if you rationalize
by multiplying the numerator and
denominator by square root of 3 over
square root of 3 you get square root 3
over 3 and that's what we have here so
you can see it's going to be a 30-degree
angle but tangents also positive over
here in the third quadrant because
basically in the third quadrant both the
X and y coordinate are going to be
negative right so that's what that looks
like right there and so what you can see
is it's going to be at third
and 210 or you could say let's just
write it over here we've got PI over six
and then also seven PI over six okay now
for 47 it asks us to give the general
solution in radians to this equation so
general as opposed to just once around
the unit circle 0 to 2pi for this
particular one what I would do is I
would factor it so this is 2 sine of X
times 1 sine of X gives us 2 sine
squared of X right and then let's see to
get negative 3 I'm sorry positive 3 we
have a negative 3 times negative 1 and
then all we have to do is check that the
inner product and the outer product add
up to this middle term negative 7 sine X
which it does so once we have it
factored all we have to do now is set
each group equal to 0 so what we have is
2 sine X minus 1 equals 0 and we have
sine X minus 3 equals 0
let's do this one first if we add 3 to
both sides we get sine of X equals 3
we're on the unit circle to sine equal 3
well know where it's only in between
negative 1 and positive 1 so that means
that this is an extraneous solution over
here what we can do is add one and then
divide both sides by 2 to get that sign
by itself where to sign equal 1/2 on the
unit circle well you can see that that's
going to be over here at 30 degrees or
your over here at 150 degrees and so in
this case this is PI over 6 so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to say PI over
6 plus multiples of 2 pi so if I go all
the way around I'm going to end up back
up the same spot same thing over here we
have 5 PI over 6 plus multiples of 2 pi
so if you go all the way around you end
up back in the same location so this
would be our general solution so that
wraps up this giant algebra 2 final exam
review subscribe to the channel check
out more math tutoring videos on my
youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
and I look forward to helping you in the
future math videos I'll talk to you soon